[Music]
6 24 on your wednesday morning hey
what's driving me crazy maybe not some
early numbers on those adaptive traffic
signals in henderson
they look kind of encouraging you know
last monday on driving crazy we talked
about this test project along eastern
between the 215 down towards anthem
where they put in about 50 cameras at 14
signals where controller computers take
in real-time traffic data at each
intersection
and adapt the timing of those signals to
ease the congestion
that has been driving you crazy county
commissioner michael naft represents the
area
he's happy with a preliminary report
in the pm hours it's actually reduced
the number of stops that a vehicle has
to make from 5.1
down to 0.9 wait what in the pm hours
it's actually reduced the number of
stops that a vehicle has to make from
5.1
down to 0.9 wow that's pretty impressive
and that says that so far
the project is a win-win-win
you've got reduction in time you've got
improved emissions we're saving the
environment but we're also reducing the
stress on people
we're always striving to do better and
we'll continue to this isn't the end of
solving the problem over there
but this is a big step in helping and
utilizing technology that is available
in this pilot program so there is an
online survey where the county the rtc
and the city of henderson want to hear
from you for that link
and this entire report you know the
drill 8 newsnow eightnewsnow.com click
traffic then driving me crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone
if there is something driving me crazy
email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com